Bitte schön.
Gut.
Guten Tag.
Ich reise Dr. Gönes.
Ich bin zuständiger als für Sie.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen dieses aneinandergespräch führen.
Ist das in Ordnung für Sie?
Ja.
Zuerst möchte ich Ihre persönliche Daten nachfragen.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Hans-Peter Neumann.
Hans-Peter ist Hans-Peter.
Hans-Peter ist Ihre Vorname, oder?
Hans und dann Bindestrich minus Peter.
Peter, okay.
Und Nachname?
Neumann.
Neumann, oder?
Sehr gut.
Wie alt sind Sie, Herr Neumann?
61.
Gut. Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 4. Februar 1963.
63.
Gut.
Herr Neumann, wie groß sind Sie?
1,79 m.
Und wie viel wiegen Sie so seit?
88 kg.
Herr Neumann, was bittst du zu uns?
Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Ja, ich habe seit einem Tag starke Schmerzen
im linken Bein.
Und die sind jetzt so starke geworden.
Also das macht mir jetzt Sorgen.
Da muss ich Sie bitten, dass Sie das abklären.
Ganzem Bein oder unter Schenkel oder oberschenkel?
Also das ganze Bein tut weh, aber besonders der Unterschenkel.
Unterschenkel, okay.
Es ist sehr unangenehme für Sie.
Das kann ich mir vorstellen.
Wie stark die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskala
von 1 bis 10 vorbei, eins sehr leicht und unterdrecklich erschmerzen?
6 bis 7.
6 bis 7, okay.
Können Sie genau beschreiben,
wie viele Schmerzen, erste Stechen, dumpf oder krampfartige schmerzen?
Einmal sind Sie hauptsächlich am Unterschenkel,
an der Außenseite.
Also außen und unter.
Okay, ja, verstehe ich.
Sie sind eher so dumpf und bohrend.
Dumpf und bohrend, ich merke.
Sie sind immer da.
Haben Sie das erste Mal gehabt?
So stark ist das jetzt ganz neu.
Seit 4 Wochen habe ich schon häufiger Schmerzen im Bein gehabt.
Besonders, wenn ich mich bewegt habe,
auf den Treppensteigen gemacht habe,
in meinem Beruf muss ich auch viel auf der Einer Treppe steigen
und auf das Dach blittern.
Ich bin Schornsteinfeger.
Und das war in letzter Zeit sehr schwierig,
weil das Bein so weht.
Okay, vor 4 Wochen haben Sie ähnliche,
aber ein bisschen leichter Beinschmerzen,
meinen Sie?
Seit 4 Wochen.
Vor 4 Wochen hat das angefangen mit Schmerzen.
Die Schmerzen waren leichter, weniger als jetzt heute und seit gestern.
Die waren leichter.
Leichter.
Aber Sie haben Schmerzen beim Treppensteigen aufgetreten.
Da ist mir das aufgefallen, beim Treppensteigen.
Und da tat das dann weh.
Und sonst muss ich viel Treppensteigen durch meinen Beruf.
Okay, aus der Schmerzen haben Sie noch Schwellungen
oder Hard-Fremderungen bemerkt?
Die Hortveränderungen nicht.
Aber seit einem Jahr habe ich auch manchmal so Kribbeln,
wie ein Kribbeln oder Ameisenlaut in dem Bein.
Das fühlt sich auch manchmal etwas taub an.
Das ist seit einem Jahr, spüre ich das.
Das ist aber auch im anderen Bein.
anderen Bein, meinen Sie?
Rechte Bein, meinen Sie?
Rechte Beinen habe ich seit einem Jahr ungefähr so Taubeizgefühle.
Taubeizgefühle, okay, verstehe ich.
Sind Sie schon einmal beim Hausarzt oder andere Arzt gewesen?
Was wurden Sie behandelt?
Ich bin häufiger bei meinem Hausarzt, weil ich auch Zucker habe.
Und da habe ihm das gesagt.
Erst allerdings beim letzten Mal vor sechs Wochen.
Und da hat er gesagt, ja, dann müssen wir das jetzt beim Neurologen
ablehren lassen.
Aber der Termin beim Neurologen, der dauert so lange.
Der ist erst in vier Wochen, habe ich einen Termin bekommen beim Neurologen.
Okay, haben Sie schon einen Termin beim Neurologen?
Termin habe ich, aber der ist erst in vier Wochen.
Okay, verstehe ich.
Wie viele Meter können Sie ohne Schmerzen laufen?
Haben Sie bemerkt?
Ja, so weit laufen tue ich sowieso nicht.
Ich bin sehr bequem.
Aber wie gesagt, beim Treppensteigen habe ich das gemerkt.
Wenn ich so zwei Stockwerke gehe, beim Gehen vielleicht so nach 200 Metern,
dann habe ich bemerkt, dass das anfängt zu schmerzen.
Dann werde ich schon mal nach 200 Metern.
Okay, Herr Neumann.
Hab allerdings immer gedacht, dass das mit meiner Hüftadrose zu tun hat.
Ich habe auf der linken Seite auch eine Hüftadrose
und die soll jetzt im Oktober operiert werden.
Da soll ich eine neue Hüfte bekommen.
Okay, haben Sie einen künstlichen Gelenk gehabt?
Soll erst gemacht werden im Oktober, jetzt im kommenden Oktober, also in sechs Monaten.
Vor sechs Monaten.
In sechs Monaten.
Es ist geplant.
Geplant, okay.
Gelenkadrose, Hüftadrose links.
Okay, Herr Neumann.
Haben Sie eine Auslöser bemerkt vor einem Jahr oder vor vier Wochen
für den Taubheißgefühl oder Beinschüme?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Der hat gesagt, eventuell hängt das mit meinem Zucker zusammen.
Okay.
Haben Sie,
fühlen Sie sich fieblich oder haben Sie Fieber?
Fieber habe ich nicht.
Schüttelfrost oder Nachtsweiß haben Sie bemerkt?
Haben Sie Probleme mit dem Stuhlgang oder Wasserlassen?
Stuhlgang ist immer regelmäßig Wasserlassen.
Ich muss einmal, manchmal zweimal in der Nacht auf Toilette und Wasser lassen.
Aber das ist für mich normal.
Ich kann danach wieder gut einschlafen.
Okay, verstehe ich.
Herr Neumann,
haben Sie sonst etwas bemerkt,
außer dieser Taubheißgefühl oder Schmerzen,
haben Sie noch weitere Bechwerden?
Achut nicht.
Achut, meine Schmerzen, deshalb ich heute zu Ihnen komme.
Okay.
Noch ein paar Fragen.
Haben Sie an der Wade
ein Hitzegefühl bemerkt
oder Warnbefer bemerkt?
Ich habe den Eindruck,
dass die Wade und der Unterschenkel kälter ist, kühler ist.
In Kühler.
Okay.
Haben Sie auch noch Haarlust bemerkt?
Haarausfall?
Haarausfall, meine ich.
Habe ich jetzt nicht drauf geachtet, kann ich nicht sagen.
Okay.
Herr Neumann,
was leiden Sie außer Altezucker an?
Chronische Krankheiten.
Haben Sie chronische Krankheiten außer Altezucker?
Und Zucker, seit sieben Jahren habe ich Zucker
und da nehme ich dann auch Tabletten ein.
Erinnern Sie sich die Namen oder Dosierung?
Das hier steht drauf, Moment,
Metformin,
Metformin, 850.
Okay.
Und morgens eine Tablette und abends eine Tablette.
Dann habe ich auch noch seit zehn Jahren hohen Blutdruck.
Okay.
Dann nehme ich auch ein Medikament, das heißt
Walzatan.
Wie schreibt man.
Walzatan V.
V-A-L-S-A-R-G-A-N.
Walsatan, okay.
Fünf hinter.
Fünf Milligramm, oder?
Eine morgens und eine abends.
Okay.
Vor drei Jahren hatte ich noch einen Bandscheibenvorfall.
einen Bandscheibenvorfall unten in der Lendenwirbelsäule und das waren auch Schmerzen, die ins Bein links ausstalten, genauso in das Bein, was jetzt auch weh tut.
Das war vor drei Jahren und das wurde beim Orthopäden mit Spritzen behandelt und auch Computer-Tomographie-Kontrolle mit Spritzen und das ist danach auch besser geworden.
Sie sind mit einem Schmess mitbehandelt.
Ja, da glaube ich auch Cortison drin.
Da musste ich dann aufpassen wegen dem Zucker, wegen Cortison.
Aber die Spritzen haben sehr gut geholfen.
Okay, gut zu hören.
Ähm, okay.
Außer dieser Krankheiten haben Sie noch etwas?
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder geregentlich Medikamente ein?
Ja, mit Formin und das Weilsatahn, die beiden Medikamente nehme ich an.
Okay, sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Ja, als Kind weiß ich nicht mehr, wie alt ich da war.
Da wurde ich an den Handeln operiert und auf der rechten Seite am Leistenbrot.
Wann war das, das zweite OP?
Da war das vielleicht zwölf Jahre alt.
Jetzt.
Dann wollte ich vor einem Jahr an der linken Hand operiert.
Hier am Handgelenk, da ist ein Nerv, war da irgendwie eingeklemmt und das kribbelte immer in den Fingern.
Da wurde dort ein kleiner Schnitt gemacht und der Nerv wurde da freigelegt, entlastet.
Dann musste ich eine Schiene tragen und danach ist das aber gut geworden.
Also, vor einem Jahr.
Vor einem Jahr.
Hatten Sie lokale Betäubung, glaube ich, oder?
Das war eine Betreuung hier oben am Arm, dabei ist es unbetäubt.
Okay.
Mit zwölf wurden Sie Leistenbruch links?
Rechts, rechts, rechts, ungefähr 12 Jahre alt und etwas einige Zeit davor,
vielleicht mit 10 Jahren, ich weiß es nicht mehr genau, wurde ich an den Handeln operiert.
Okay.
Neumann, rauchen Sie?
Ja, ja, leider.
Ich rauche jeden Tag eine Schachtel Zigaretten.
Ich habe schon 40 Jahre lang.
Seit 40 Jahren, oder?
Haben Sie schon einmal gedacht,
dass die Zigaretten rauf und aufhören?
Ich nicht, ich nicht, aber meine Frau und meine Kinder, die wollen, dass ich aufhöre zu rauchen,
aber bisher habe ich da noch nicht zu entscheßen können.
Ja, ich würde gerne für Sie einen Termin vereinbaren in unseren Krankenhausen.
Aber erst mal möchte ich, dass die Schmerzen weg sind im Bein.
Ja, natürlich.
Trinken Sie geregelt oder regeln Sie sich Alkohol?
Ich trinke abends so 1 bis 2 Flaschen Bier, so die kleinen Flaschen, 0,3.
1 bis 2 Flaschen, aber keine Schnepse oder so, wenn ich was trinke probiere.
Okay.
Nehmen Sie die folgende Frage, bitte nicht persönlich.
Haben Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Nein.
Na, schön.
Sind Ihnen eine Allergie oder Unverträchtlichkeit bekannt?
Nein.
Okay, gut.
Sind Sie in der letzten Zeit im Ausland, in den Tropen oder so gewesen?
Nein, in den Tropen bin ich nicht.
Ich fliege nicht gerne, ich habe Angst vorm Fliegen.
Und dann mache ich Ferien mit dem Auto.
Wir sind auch nach Österreich gefahren oder nach Belgien.
Aber wir verreisen nicht groß, wir bleiben dann mehr in der Gegend bei uns.
Ja, okay, wichtig.
In der letzten Seite haben Sie Langereise gemacht?
Haben Sie Langereise gemacht?
Ich bin es zwei Wochen, nicht länger.
Okay.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Also das letzte Mal habe ich meinen Impfpass beim Hausarzt vorgelegt und der war zufrieden.
Er sagt im Augenblick brauchen wir keine weiteren Impfungen.
Ich hatte jetzt wieder eine Grippeimpfung im Herbst und wir Covid-Impfungen.
Und die anderen sind, glaube ich, auf dem Stand.
Okay.
Noch ein paar Fragen haben wir.
Leben Ihre Eltern noch, Neumann?
Der Vater, der lebt nicht mehr, der ist im Alter von 78 Jahren verstorben.
Und da hieß es, er ist verstorben, weil seine Schlagader, seine Bauchschlagader geplatzt war.
Okay.
Und Bauchschlagader?
Wahrscheinlich war da irgendeine, wie nennt sich das, Aussackung.
Und das ist nicht erkannt worden und die ist geplatzt.
Da ist er.
Bei der OP ist er gestorben oder nach?
Er ist schon in der Ambulanz verstorben, als er eingeliefert wurde.
Er hat sich in der Ambulanz gestorben.
Er ist schon in der Ambulanz verstorben, als er eingeliefert wurde im Krankenhaus.
Man hat dann irgendwas untersucht mit einem Kontrastmittel oder einem Gefäß.
Jedenfalls hat man wohl festgestellt, da ist die Schlagader geplatzt.
Okay.
Mutter, die lebt, die ist 86 Jahre alt, die ist stark verwirrt.
Altersverwirrung.
Sie hat auch eine starke Lungenüberblähung,
sodass sie schlecht Luft bekommt, braucht manchmal Sauerstoff.
Ja.
Für einen Bruder, der ist 58 Jahre alt, der hat auch hohen Blutdruck.
58 Jahre alt, okay.
Ich könnte nicht verstehen, was ihr Mutter leidet an.
Könnten Sie wiederholen?
Mutter ist sehr verwirrt.
Okay, verstehe ich.
Sie hat eine Probleme mit der Lunge.
Die Lunge ist, heißt es immer, sie ist überblät die Lunge.
Ich kann den Begriff nicht, den Fachbegriff nicht.
Die Lungenüberblähung und dann kriegt sich sehr schlecht Luft.
Manchmal braucht sie Sauerstoff.
Sauerstoff.
Okay.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja.
Wohne mit meiner Frau zusammen?
Gut.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Zwei, die sind 31 Jahre alt und 33 Jahre alt.
Die wohnen aber nicht mehr bei uns hier in der Stadt.
Die sind woanders hinbezogen.
Die beiden sind hoffentlich gesund.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Schornsteinfeger.
Wie viele können Sie wiederholen?
Einfeger.
Die Kamine in den Häusern müssen gereinigt werden.
Wenn das Haus eine Heizung hat oder einen Ofen hat,
dann muss der Rauch durchs Dach abziehen.
Das ist ein Schornstein.
Schornstein.
Soll ich das Buch stabilieren?
Nein.
Schornstein.
S, C, H.
Okay.
O.
R, N, S, C, E, I, N.
Und ich bin ein Schornsteinfeger.
Ich reinige diese Schornsteine von Russ und von...
Schornsteinbelegung.
Okay.
Ich denke,
alle Fragen habe ich gestellt.
Haben Sie noch Fragen an mich?
Ja, ich frage Sie, was kann das sein, diese starken Schmerzen?
Das macht mir Sorgen.
Ja, ich möchte...
Ich kann noch nicht sagen, was Sie haben, Herr Neumann.
Wir müssen
ein paar Untersuchungen gehen,
zuerst körperliche Untersuchungen
und bildgebende Verfahren durchführen.
Wir arbeiten hier ein großes erfahrenes Team.
Deswegen
sobald alle Ergebnisse vorlegen haben,
nach der
meiner Obarbesprechung werde ich Sie informieren,
was Sie genau haben.
Okay.
Machen Sie sich bitte keine Sorge,
nehmen Sie einen Platz in der
Untersuchungshimmer.
Danke.
Gut.
Dann haben Sie jetzt ja etwas Zeit, nicht ganz so lange wie in der Prüfung,
die
Patientensprache zu übersetzen in medizinische Ausdrücke und
wenn dieinnen und Kollegen aus dem großen Auditorium
Fragen oder Ergänzungen haben, bitte.
Ich habe...
Ja, ich habe Fragen.
Ja.
Herr Neumann,
Verwässerende, ist es richtig Schmerzen bei Ruhe?
Also Sie tun auch in Ruhe, habe ich Schmerzen.
Es wird sicherlich etwas schlimmer, wenn ich mich bewege.
Aber ich habe mich in den letzten Stunden eigentlich gar nicht mehr bewegt, weil
selbst der Ruhe-Schmerz war schon so stark.
Ja.
Verstehe.
Die zweite Frage ist, wie ist die aktuelle Situation
bezüglich des Bandscheibenvorfalls?
Wurden Sie in der letzten Zeit untersucht?
Nein.
In letzter Zeit habe ich da
diesbezüglich keine großen Beschwerden gehabt.
Wobei aber der Schmerz war eben auch ähnlich in das Bein rein, so stark
und war auch ziemlich stark der Schmerz.
Das war vor drei Jahren.
Ja.
Die nächste Frage ist, können Sie eine Unterschied
in der Farbe, dicke der beide Beine feststellen?
Da habe ich jetzt nicht darauf geachtet.
Ich habe nur bemerkt, dass das linke Bein irgendwie etwas kühler ist.
Die Temperatur ist etwas geringer.
Aber nicht geschwollen, oder?
Ja, nicht.
Nein.
Okay, genug drei Fragen.
Noch eine Frage haben Kollegen.
Ja, ich habe.
Bitte schön.
Ja.
Ist Ihnen schon der?
Nein.
Wann war das Leste, Blutdruck?
Blutdruck, messe ich unregelmäßig.
Meine Frau, die sagt immer, jetzt musst du wieder Blutdruck messen.
Das war, glaube ich, vor einer Woche habe ich mal gemessen.
Da habe ich so ein Gerät, da ist so ein Speicher.
Da kann ich die Werte dann abspeichern.
Ich glaube, der Wert war so knapp 150 auf 90.
Das war vor acht Tagen.
Blutdrucker habe ich auch gemessen.
Der war einmal morgens vor dem Frühstück, war er 140.
Und dann habe ich ihn nach dem Frühstück gemessen,
zwei Stunden nach dem Frühstück und da war er 170.
Blutdrucker Langzeitwert war in letzter Zeit immer leicht erhöht,
sagt der Hausarzt.
Ich müsste eigentlich ein bisschen Gewicht abnehmen, sagt er.
Aber ich habe bisher nicht geschafft.
Ich habe eine Frage auch.
Ich habe nicht verstanden,
vor zwei Wochen haben Sie mit Ihrem Auto
ins Ausland gereist oder nicht?
Nein, ich verreise, wenn wir Urlaub machen,
Ferien machen, verreisen wir mit dem Auto.
Aber vor zwei Wochen nicht, wenn wir waren,
nur ich wurde gefragt, wie lange war die Reise?
Die waren höchstens immer zwei Wochen.
Aber das ist jetzt schon fünf Monate her, der letzte Urlaub.
Okay, danke schön.
Noch andere Fragen, Kollege?
Ja, ich habe zwei Fragen.
Ja, danke schön.
Ich denke, noch weiter.
Ein oder zwei genug?
Zwei.
Okay.
Also Herr Neumann, haben Sie Atemnutz?
Haben Sie bemerkt?
Nein, Atemnutz habe ich nicht.
Ich habe manchmal Husten, aber das hängt mit meinem Rauchen zusammen.
Okay.
Atemnutz habe ich nicht.
Und Hetra sind?
Haben Sie bemerkt?
Okay, vielen Dank.
Ja, sehen Sie gut, Herr Neumann?
Sehen Sie gut?
Oder verschwommen Sie hin?
Ich kann noch gut sehen.
Sind bei Ihnen allergün Dumpferklichkeit bekannt?
Nein, das hat der Kollege aber schon gefragt.
Ja, erster Druck, ob ich nicht gewusst habe.
Okay, danke schön.
Okay, ich denke alle Fragen sind getestet.
Gut, ich gehe jetzt an, Kollege.
Haben Sie etwas dagegen eingenommen?
Gegen die Schmerzen?
Ja.
Ich habe vor einigen Stunden eine Tablette Paracetamol genommen.
Aber das hat nicht geholfen.
Vielen Dank. Können wir als erstes ein bisschen anfangen?
Herr Oberst?
Ich kann, ich bin bereit.
Bitte schön.
Okay, guten Abend Herr Oberst.
Ich habe eine neue Patiente aufgenommen.
Haben Sie eine Kurse Zeit, die den Patienten vorzustellen?
Hab ich.
Herr Petra Neumann, ein 60-jähriger Patient,
stellte sich heute
Bein und Alli nicht.
Seit einem Tag starke linken Bein,
besonders unter Schenkel.
Wo?
Die Schmerzen liegt
6 bis 7 auf einer Schmerzkala.
Die Schmerzen sind ehe
Dumpf und bohrende.
Seit 4 Wochen hat er
ähnliche Leichte beschwerden.
Er hat seit 4 Wochen
Belastung abgewogen.
Aber jetzt in Ruhe.
Er klagte
in den Schmerzen.
Er hat seit 4 Wochen
eine Schmerzengeläufe.
einen Schmerzengeläufer geklagt.
Er klagte
auch
vor einem Jahr
Parästhesie und Hypesthesie
in linken Bein.
Seit einem Jahr.
Ja, in der Vagin-Tiefe an Amnesi
wurden bis auf Necturie
1-2 Mal in der Nacht.
In der Vorgeschichte
hatte er
der Bethesemelitus seit 20 Jahren
und Arterie Lehipatoni seit
10 Jahren.
Der Bethesemelitus typ 2 seit 7 Jahren.
Seit 7 Jahren.
Seit 7 Jahren
und Arterie Lehipatoni seit 10 Jahren
dagegen nehmen er regelmäßig
mit Formin
150 Milligramm, einmal morgens, einmal abends.
Und Walzartan 5 Milligramm,
einmal morgens, einmal abends.
Darüber hinaus leidet er
Kokosartos links.
Und
für die wurde ein
Tep links geplant.
Und er leidet auch
Diskusprolaps
in den Ländern in Bad Wulje.
Wann die Tep, die Hüfttep
stattfinden soll?
In 6 Monaten.
Okay, gut.
Okay, vor Operationen.
Ich habe gerade Entschuldigung,
Sie haben noch etwas von einem Diskusprolaps berichtet.
Können Sie da näheres zu sagen,
wann war dieser Diskusprolaps?
Wann war dieser Diskusprolaps?
Seit 4 Jahren
hat er
vor 3 Jahren
ein
Cortison-Schiebditz gehabt.
Aber was war vor 3 Jahren die Diagnose?
Ein Diskusprolaps, wo war der Diskusprolaps?
In der HWS?
LBS.
Okay, gut.
Und dann hatte der Patient
Schmerzen,
Ichalgie-Form, Ichers-Schmerzen.
Wenn er es ist, Ichers-Schmerzen.
Ja, wahrscheinlich hatte er
Ichalgie, aber...
Wo?
Der Patient hat auch gesagt, wo der Schmerz war.
Das habe ich nicht genau gefragt.
In der Untersuchung werde ich nachfragen.
Jetzt war im linken Unterschenkel.
Auch im linken Unterschenkel
so ein ähnlicher Schmerz, wie es jetzt ist,
aktuell, wahrscheinlich
dem Segment 11-5-Zusuch.
Wahrscheinlich 11-5.
Und dieses wurde dann mit
Injektionen behandelt.
Wie war der Verlauf?
Hat es sich gebessert unter den Injektionen?
Ja, nach der Cortison
hat sich verbessert.
Ich fasse kurz zusammen, was ich jetzt
von Ihnen gehört habe.
Hans-Peter Neumann, der Vorname ist
Hans-Peter Neumann.
Hans ist Einnahme
und minus oder Binde-Peter.
Das ist ein Doppelname, ist in Deutschland relativ geläufig.
Das ist zwei Namen.
Hans-Peter, Nachname Neumann.
Er ist ein 61-Jähriger Patient.
Herr Neumann berichtet über
starke Schmerzen
seit ungefähr einem Tag.
Diese Schmerzen werden als
dumpf und bohrend beschrieben
und auf der Schmerzkala
von 1-10 zwischen 6 und 7
eingestuft.
Herr Neumann berichtet
seit einigen Wochen bestehende
Schmerzen in Beinen, die aber nicht
so stark seien und die mehr bei
Belastung auftreten.
Können Sie mir sagen, was Herr Neumann
an Belastungen hat? Können Sie mir
etwas über seinen Beruf sagen?
Er ist Schornstein-Plägerin.
Schornstein-Pfeger.
Schornstein, was müssen Sie am besten
nochmal in Ihrem Wörterbuch nachsehen?
Schornstein-Pfeger, was das für ein Begriff ist
in Ihrer Heimatsprache?
Schornstein-Pfeger.
Die Menschen sind so ganz schwarz gekleidet
und haben viel Ruß im Gesicht, weil sie
an den Terminen arbeiten.
Deutschland ist ein sehr wichtiger Beruf,
weil jeder Mensch muss seinen Schornstein
pflegen lassen von der Behörde.
Herr Neumann, was ist das für ein Begriff?
Schornstein-Pfeger.
Er ist ein sehr großer Kronker.
Er leidet auch
Cox-Arthor.
Und Discus Prolabs 11.
Gut.
Hat Herr Neumann noch andere Beschwerden
zu tun?
Ja, das habe ich gesagt.
Parästhesie und Schülpesthesie
in
Rechtenbeinen.
Es besteht darüber hinaus,
es besteht Kribbelparästhesie in beiden Beinen.
Schon glaube ich seit einem Jahr.
Das soll abgeklärt werden.
Ich habe noch eine Erinnerung bei Neurologen.
Aber der Termin ist erst in vier Wochen.
Ist das richtig?
Ja, das ist richtig.
Gut.
Bittes Auffälligkeiten bei den Risikofaktoren
des Patienten, bei den persönlichen?
Ja, er ist starker Rauch.
Seit 40 Jahren, das heißt 40 Packages.
Er trinkt regelmäßig
ein bis zwei Flasche Bier
täglich.
Und
in der Reiseanamese
oder
Reiseanamese ist unaufwählig.
Gut.
In der Familienanamese.
Sein Vater
ist mit
78 wegen
Annegrisma-Ruptura verstorben.
Annegrisma-Ruptura
ist
wahrscheinlich Bauch-Anegrisma.
Abdominaler.
Abdominaler-Anegrism.
Abdominaler-Arort-Nanorism.
Wahrscheinlich.
Gut. Und die Mutter?
Die Mutter
in 86 Jahren
leidet an
Demenz
und auch
Anfiseme.
Lungenüberbähung,
kann man ruhig sagen,
das Lungenempfiseme ist teilweise
sauerstopfrichtig.
Okay.
Sein 58-Jahre-Bruder
leidet auch
an Arterele
Schippe-Toni.
Er ist verheiratet, hat zwei gesunde Kinder.
Das war's, glaube ich.
An Risikofaktoren würde ich zusammenfassen,
der Patient ist ein starker Raucher.
Es besteht ein langjähriger Nikotin
ab Usus über 40 Packages.
Ein regelmäßiger Alkoholkonsum.
Es besteht ein Übergewicht.
Er ist 1,79 und 88 Kilo.
Kann man von Übergewicht sprechen,
noch nicht Adipositas.
Er hat einen artigellen Hypertonus.
Er hat ein Diabetes-Veletus Typ 2.
Und diese Risikokonstellation ist natürlich
eventuell prädestiliert
für die Verdachtsdiagnose, die Sie mir bitte nennen.
Dann fragen Sie meine Verdachtdiagnose, oder?
Im Großen und Ganzen denke ich an
perferielle Arterelleverschlusskrankheit.
Aber kommen auch
...
hatte schon
ein Dispustprolaps, der sich in der
Verwaltung der Diabetes-Veletus
verwendet hat.
Deswegen könnte auch
...
Das Ganze kann überlagert werden.
Ich glaube nicht, dass es alkoholbedingt ist.
Dazu ist mir der Alkoholkonsum doch zu moderat,
aber durch den Diabetes wahrscheinlich.
Also der PAVK, ein Zustand nach Discos Prolapse
wird eventuell im Rezidiv.
Es besteht eine diabetesche Neuropathie.
Das sind schon mal drei wichtige Diagnosen,
die abgeklärt werden sollten.
Alles andere wäre nachgeordnet.
Die Frage eventuell nach einem Zeckebiss,
eine Borreliose oder so etwas der Schmerz
oder die Symptomatik beginnt eher so schleichend.
Harte ich jetzt nicht für so ganz zwingend,
aber vielleicht sollte man das im Rahmen
von serologischer Diagnostik auch mit einbeziehen und abklären.
Beginnender Herr Bistoster ohne Hautepfloristenzen,
wobei Kollegen haben gefragt,
ist die Haut verändert?
Konnte der Patient nicht genau sagen, der Patient hat nur gesagt,
die Haut ist etwas pälter oder kühler.
Eventuell doch eher für eine PAVK sprechen.
Das ist schwer, die echte Krankheiten zu unterschälen.
Wichtig ist jetzt nicht, die richtige Diagnose zu stellen,
sondern, dass sie die Verdachtsdiagnose benennen können
und auch Differenzialdiagnosen benennen.
Das ist für das Training entscheidend.
Nicht zu sagen, sie liegen mit der Diagnose ganz richtig.
Gut, danke, dass Sie sich zur Verfügung gestellt haben.
Ich finde, Sie haben das sehr ruhig und systematisch gemacht.
Der erste Satz ist immer mit der Schwierigste,
wenn Sie berichten, warum der Patient kommt.
Ich glaube, es immer wieder versuchen Sie eher,
einen einfachen Satz zu machen in der Einleitung.
Der Patient stellt sich wegen starker,
Beinschmerzen links, ungefähr seit 24 Stunden vor Punkt
und dann einen neuen Satz bilden,
weil sonst wird das in der Formulierung manchmal sehr schwierig.
Ich würde es einfach so rumvorschlagen.
Es gibt ja andere Strategien,
aber es ist manchmal mit der Grammatik schwierig
und was habe ich jetzt gesagt und passt das noch.
Es ist einfach nur mein Vorschlag.
Danke für die Empfehlung, Gennem.